Pixar it's nice to have you back inside
out now I was a bit nervous going into
this one Pixar has had a bit of a rough
run as far as I'm concerned they haven't
made a good movie since toy story 3 and
they haven't made a great one since up
thankfully things are back on track with
this one because this movie is fun it's
funny it's touching it is everything I
want out of a great Pixar movie but was
afraid to expect anymore so inside out
deals with a young girl by the name of
Riley she's 11 years old and her family
is just moved from Minnesota to San
Francisco now a move that big that
drastic that's a lot for anyone to deal
with and it's a lot to ask of a kid and
we get a special look inside of her mind
at her emotions as they try and guide
Riley through everything that's going on
to get the best result there are five
emotions that we deal with there is joy
sadness fear disgust and anger and
between the five of them they try and
help shape why these experiences to help
build the best core memories which
helped build and create the personality
that actually makes her who she is now
even beyond Pixar's track record the
premise had me a little bit worried as
well because it seems like the kind of
thing that is not a bad idea but it
doesn't seem like the kind of thing and
it's gonna sustain for a full-length
feature it seemed like the kind of thing
that would be great for a 10-15 minutes
short half hour at the stretch and i
also found myself wondering like how is
there gonna be any sort of dynamic
interaction with these emotions you know
how how can they have a journey how can
they learn anything how can an emotion
have an arc thankfully the film really
does balance things all really well and
it stays true to what these emotions are
meant to represent but even though they
are very strongly defined by a single
characteristic which is just implied by
what their names are there is still a
surprising amount of depth and there is
a roundness to each of these characters
plus the whole movie bounces around the
five of them plus what's going on in the
real
world often and frequently enough that
if there ever was a risk that things
were gonna start to get stale or the
premise was going to start to wear thin
it knows when to move to something else
to keep everything fresh I don't want to
go too much into the story beyond just
the initial setup because I think what
they do is really clever in the way that
they find a way to to stretch out the
story and what's going on in Riley's
life and what's going on inside her head
is just everything is just really
well-balanced and very well thought out
the voice cast is also very good it's
not really worth singling out all the
voices because really across the board
it's just great voice work which is
standard on a Pixar movie even the Pixar
movies that I don't really like or I
think are overrated always have stellar
voice work the animation and the look of
everything especially inside ryland said
is also really interesting in its it's
also very intuitive you're just looking
at it they explain the few things that
are sort of unique concepts to how this
sort of vision of insight you're handed
in someone's mind works but for the most
part you just look at it and you pretty
much immediately get what everything is
meant to be and what things are meant to
represent and that's just really clever
design and really well thought out ways
of telling us a lot without having to
sit us down and throw exposition at us
there's a little bit at the front end
but only as much as you need and then
just the visuals tell you everything you
need to know now we're talking Pixar and
we're talking about a movie about
feelings so yeah there's some pretty
serious emotions in this one and yes I
did cry I cried flat out once and I
choked up well ahead of that because of
something else but now he was really
sort of where it shows the strength of
this film though the thing that made me
cry like flat-out cry tears going down
the face was something that I saw coming
I saw it set up and I knew exactly what
was gonna happen and it did happen how I
thought it was gonna happen and I knew
they were gonna play it up as a sad
moment but it still made me cry even
though I saw it coming was just speaks
to the strength of the execution and how
genuine the emotions this thing is able
to dredge up from the audience are and
while the Pixar film it's easy to get
hung up on the moments that make you cry
but there's a lot of funny funny stuff
in this one of the really nice things
about the
having it set inside of Riley's mind
it's you can basically throw out the
normal laws of physics so they're able
to have a lot more almost sort of looney
tunes type of physical gags that Pixar
doesn't usually get to have because
their films are just slightly to
grounded in reality that you can't have
people just splatting against the wall
in a way that completely reshapes their
body because you know that's just a
little too cartoonish for the sorts of
worlds that they make but when you're
dealing with the world that is entirely
mental you can get away with that level
of physical comedy so there's that but
there's also really clever writing to
some really funny dialogue just this
movie is the complete package kids are
gonna love it because it's fun and it's
funny and it's energetic and its
brightly colored but not in that sort of
distract the kids with shiny obviously
no it's just bright and vibrant and
lively and adults are gonna like it
because it really does speak very
truthfully to your emotional levels and
how you process information and sort of
different aspects of your personality
sort of taking control and take you in
the driver's seat as different things
happen in your life and I think anyone
of any age is going to be able to relate
and connect to that and go yeah yeah
this is pics are back on point and back
and form and I I feel like I've been
waiting a while for this to happen and
it was worth the wait that is not an
excuse to give us more junk like cars
too though guys come on let's keep on
the ball now I think I asked this what I
talked about brave but I'll ask it again
anyways what is your favorite Pixar film
i think i might have said be Incredibles
last time for whatever reason up slip my
mind up is my favorite Pixar film but
there are a lot of good ones out there
what is your favorite whatever one it is
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it as for me I'll be
back as soon as I can get my next fix
you